all right darius how are you i'm doing
well man it's a lot going on markets a
lot going on in the economy man this is
a fun time to be in macro
let's start first with yesterday because
i or on wednesday i'm sorry 75 basis
point hike from the federal reserve uh
their entire talk track all their
talking points
a recession is not here we do not see a
recession
we do not believe the united states
economy is in a recession
first
why are they raising interest rates at
75 basis points and being so aggressive
if the last one didn't work
well give the guys some credit uh their
monetary policy at least according to
them and i would tend to agree with this
takes time to filter through the economy
um you know it doesn't impact everyone
because there's a lot of debt that's not
on floating rate basis there's a lot of
debt that's obviously on fixed rate
including most mortgages so it takes
time for you know for uh you know
incremental consumers and incremental um
sort of people who are tapping debt
markets to really feel the impact of
that so ultimately what the policy
choices that they're making today are
intended to have an impact on the
economy let's call it uh the general
consensus on this is somewhere between
two to three to four quarters down the
road as we look at 75 basis points
50 was kind of the general thought
process a couple of months ago then they
jacked up the 75. could they go to a
hundred do you think 75 is kind of the
upper bound of what is possible
yeah in fact i mean it's probably the
last 75 basis point hike we're likely to
get um if you think about sort of so 100
basis points are sort of uh that was
shot for dad really quickly um on the
other side of that inflation report the
uh we sent out and that we
see sent out bullard and walla to sort
of uh tap that down but as it relates to
um you know the continuation of 75 basis
points we're probably going to have to
see inflation pressure continue to build
from here
now it's not necessarily likely to
continue to build particularly on the
headline side because we have seen a a
pretty significant decline in energy and
agriculture prices that should start to
feed through into headline cpi we do
however see core cbi pressures continue
to build this is something we talked
about last on the show with the new
acceleration to an all-time high median
cpi on a three-month annualized basis
sticky cpi accelerated to 40 a year high
on uh in terms of on a theoreticalized
basis as well so we are seeing a kind of
a new push higher its core inflation but
it might be overwhelmed by um declining
food and energy prices as it relates to
headline
as we begin to look at some of those
inflation measurements uh they continue
to talk about 9.1 percent uh in a couple
weeks ago you and i were talking and you
were talking about the acceleration of
kind of the three-month uh annualized
inflation do you think that that plays
into kind of their continued
aggressiveness is even though they only
talk about europe
this is a problem right like we all know
that inflation should eventually come
down on a year over your rate of change
basis just due to base effects um we
don't need to unpack base effects here
that's probably not the right audience
but um but the problem with you know
kind of anchoring on base effects to get
inflation down which i think a lot of
investors are making this mistake which
is if you only rely on base effects to
get inflation down you're going to wind
up with a structurally higher kind of a
base rate based level of inflation by
the end of that process and so it's my
belief and and i think you know just
based on the kind of the tea leaves we
continue to hear out of fed over out of
fed heads and obviously out of power
yesterday is that the annualized the
momentum the sequential change in
inflation is really what's driving the
boat from a policy standpoint and the
most recent data points we're getting
you know if you look at on a three-month
annualized rate of change basis like
pretty much everything in the entire
inflation basket is accelerating to the
upside with the exception of energy so i
mean that's um that's an issue for the
fed uh is really an issue for markets
quite frankly because it means you know
that inflation is likely to continue
being a problem for longer than the sort
of you know the growth dynamics in the
in the economy uh would appreciate let's
talk about the labor market i know
you've got this chart here that shows
the labor market is too strong
for the fed to stop tightening that
seems to be one of two things they
continue to point to even though gdp
growth is negative now for two
consecutive quarters they say hey
employment looks strong and consumer
spending still looks pretty healthy
what's going on in the labor market
yeah great question man so the reason i
sent you a bunch of charts most of them
are all around the labor market the
reason i sent those charts is because we
can unpack all of them
the fed is now shifting its sort of
focus back in the direction of its dual
mandate you know obviously it has the
price stability mandate but it also has
the maximum employment mandate so
yesterday it gave the investors sort of
um it kind of tipped its cap and nodded
to investors who are increasingly
concerned about growth and the
possibility of what we call a hashtag
actual recession which is different uh
than the technical recession that was
reported today uh so going back to the
labor market the strength of the labor
market powell effectively said very
clearly and cogently hey look the late
market is too strong for us you anyone
to be worried about recession right now
um and so this is i'm going to putting
up that chart uh uh slide 82 from our
macroscopic report uh just shows um you
know kind of three main indicators that
i think the fed is anchoring on to give
them um to give them confidence that the
late market is really strong so the
first uh
plot in the upper panel just shows the
ratio between
total job openings and total unemployed
people and at 1.9 x uh which is where we
are today with the red dotted line you
know we're you know more than double
that you know sort of the pre-covet
trend of 0.9 which is the blue dotted
line and that chart um the middle panel
shows the private sector quits rate so
this is the percentage of people who
have jobs uh that are quitting uh in any
given month and obviously when you quit
your job it's usually to go find a a
better job or a higher paying job et
cetera like that so it's an indication
of how tight the labor market is
that number is at 3.1 percent coming off
an all-time high last fall relative and
that's much higher than the uh you know
pre-covert trend of 2.4 and then lastly
the bottom panel
we show the employment cost index which
is the broadest measure of wages of
broadest measure of you know sort of
wages in the in the economy and that
number at 4.5 percent is is effectively
a double of the 2.5 percent pre-coveted
trend so when the fed looks at these
statistics it's seeing a labor market
that is way too hot to stop tightening
if they're going to um if they're
looking at growth as a sort of indicator
that they can slow down on tightening
and anchoring the that segment of growth
indicators on the labor market blade
market is not going to give them any
signals anytime soon
as you think about this labor market
how do you measure we're seeing
at least headlines
layoffs hiring freezes like i kind of
think of it as uh there's a wall and
there's cracks in the wall now
and sure the dam hasn't bust yet we're
not at you know four and a half five
percent unemployment or anything like
that
but it does feel like we're kind of
starting to see the cracks we're seeing
tick up just a little bit is that
something that you worry about or do you
think that we'll have such a
kind of multi-month you know uh headway
or runway to actually see
that market changing and it'll give them
enough time to kind of change their mind
because it won't happen overnight where
we just go from you know 3.6 to 4.5
unemployment
yeah so to be clear it could happen
overnight it's just very unlikely to
happen overnight um and the reason i say
that is that you know we have not seen a
significant enough decline in sort of
aggregate income consumer spending you
know con
and sort of a non-residential fixed
investment business investment to really
kind of get you kind of concerned about
a jump condition lower in the total
employment and in jobs market um the
reality is going back to the headlines
we're seeing we certainly are starting
to see cracks in the dam i mean you know
you can start to piece together all
these different companies telling you
that hey we're laying off i don't know
10 000 people or 10 percent of our
workforce or we're freezing hiring and
all that stuff's going to get worse and
worse and worse on an extended period of
over extended period of time because
again the labor market is lagging with
respect to the economic cycle with
respect to the market cycle you know
when you look at the labor market and
one we're going back to some of these
headlines right you know the headlines
make the news right the headlines would
get you to click on the article but no
one's going to put out a headline that
says company xyz is increasing hiring by
10 000 or company abc is actually
increasing his workforce by 10
but that's actually what's been
happening if you go to slide 83 that
next chart pump
where we show i think we talked about
this chart after the jobs report a few
weeks ago but it's important to sort of
reiterate for those who missed that show
which is the labor market is is
overheating by double i mean we kind of
alluded to that in the previous chart
but this next chart uh slide 83 where we
show private payrolls growth uh that's
the first cluster of bars the light blue
bars the the pre-covert trend the
five-year trend through 2019 the dark
blue bars the most recent month june is
the most recent jobs report we have and
so at 3.4 percent of private payrolls
growth on a three-month annualized basis
that's literally more than double than
where we um you know what we saw on the
in the pre-covert trend average hourly
earnings that second customer bars 5.8
you know basically double uh the
pre-covert trend as well and then lastly
the last cluster of bars we show
aggregate labor income you know growing
at eight percent i mean
versus a pre-covert trend four point
four percent i mean it's telling you
that you know the media are doing a very
poor job of actually reporting the labor
market from a balanced perspective you
know the reality is the league market
continues and begin because it's a
lagging indicator it's lagging all the
growth that we had last year it's
lagging the all-time highs we saw in
january the reason those things continue
to be very robust is because again it's
a lagging indicator
as we then go and we look at this next
chart that you sent us this uh a whole
idea of the depressed labor supply might
delay the economy's natural response to
declining corporate profitability uh
one thing i continue to go back to is
the free market
i would think would be smarter than
central banks or central planning uh
what you're talking about here is this
depressed labor supply and the economy's
natural response unpack that a little
bit so that we can understand kind of
what do you mean by the economy's
natural response and then how does
things like the depressed labor supply
uh and corporate profitability play in
100 man i think this is one of the most
important and underrated kind of um
aspects of the labor market right now
which is you know so you kind of alluded
to like how long will it take for the
sort of dams and the system the cracks
in the dam to really start to you know
give way to a bigger flood and the
reality is it might actually take longer
in this cycle than in previous cycles
which the key takeaway from what i just
said is the fed is likely to keep its
foot on the brake for longer but let me
unpack this chart so what we show in the
chart uh in these four panels the first
panel is the overall labor force
participation rate in the economy this
is the sort of percent of people uh you
know who are non-institutionalized not
in jail effectively um or
you know joe mooney bin or whatever you
want to call it um those are those are
um the relative proportion of people who
are actively engaged in the labor market
looking for jobs et cetera et cetera um
then you have the 25 to 54 year olds uh
in the uh in the second panel 55 plus
year olds so people nearing retirement
and the third panel and then last of the
female labor force participation rate
and what you can see is that we've seen
a broad-based decline in the labor force
participation rate you know the headline
is off 120 basis points from where it
was at pre-kovic
the prime working age 25 to 54 people
who should not you should be working by
all strengths and all stretches of the
imagination are it's down 80 basis
points in the pre-covert high uh 55 plus
roles the great resignation you know
people finally retiring the baby boomers
retiring that's down 170 basis points
from speak over high and then we also
have female labor force participation
rate down 110 basis points so all you
take all these different sort of pockets
of the labor market together these
different cohorts it's telling you that
companies there's a real scarcity of
workers out there that may make
companies a little bit reluctant at the
margins to shed you know some of the the
highers that they've accumulated in the
last so it's called six to six to 18
months and so that may actually again
the title of the chart being what it is
it may slow you know the natural sort of
hiring and firing cycle may slow the
firing cycle in this cycle relative to
previous cycles which again keeps the
fed actively engaged in tightening
policy because they're looking at the
labor market to give them clues to stop
and then you've got this it may be quite
a while before the fetish freaked out
about the labor market uh chart what is
this showing us
see what
yeah this one yeah so no this um the
blue line in this chart shows uh the
conference boards uh labor differential
survey so the within the consumer
confidence index report uh we get from
the conference board they have sort of
two questions which is you know uh
what's the percentage of respondents who
think jobs will be plentiful six months
hence and then once the percentage of
respondents who think jobs will be uh
less plentiful six months and so they
take the differential of those surveys
as a sort of proxy for how robust the
labor market is and as you can see you
know going back to q1 of this year we're
effectively coming off an all-time high
in consumers perception of the labor
market you know even even with the
decline we've seen since then we're
still in the 95th percentile of all
readings in this survey going back to i
want to say the 60s or 70s i mean it is
a lot it's a long time series history of
telling you how tight or weak the labor
market is and we're coming off you know
the all-time types and so it's telling
you that hey look there's a lot of
downside to go before the fed is
probably concerned about the labor
market like us market participants we
care about the rate of change the
direction of travel how fast is it
moving the fed cares about is this good
or bad and it's going to take a while
before to actually get bad and that may
actually keep the fed engaged in
tightening monetary policy rate hikes
quantitative tightening for longer than
it probably otherwise should because
we're likely to head into a recession
let's call it sometime by the end of
this year maybe even beginning part of
next year
when you start to look out at the market
more generally does the fed care about
asset prices like those have fallen
they seem to have been somewhat immune
to caring but what's your general read
yeah no that's a great question man um
so yes but not in the
price level sense they care about asset
prices in the sense that if we're seeing
sort of you know sloppy trading in the
treasury market like wider bid x spreads
um you know inability for corporations
to sort of uh place debt to issue debt
and you're seeing sort of dysfunction in
the in the repo market uh which is used
to sort of capitalize uh shadow bank
participants you know if we're seeing
dysfunction there then you know then yes
the fed is really going to be concerned
because usually dysfunction there
translates to higher volatility in the
actual asset prices and ultimately
usually higher volatility is leading uh
to lower prices and so yes the fed does
care but they only care in the sense
that we're seeing real confirmed signs
of financial instability and some would
argue we're starting to see that you're
seeing things like repo fails or which
is probably too sophisticated subject to
talk about here but you're seeing things
like rebel fails obviously the move
index which is a bond the vix for the
treasury market has been elevated all
year so there's there's definitely some
elements of financial instability but
nothing like what we've seen even in
2019 even in 2018 even in 2015-16 so i
don't think the fed is that particularly
concerned about it here and nor should
they be right again inflation is at 9.1
percent year-over-year annualizing at 11
they should they don't have the the
ability to be concerned right now
and
what about the data one of the things
that jerome powell said yesterday uh
which i'm still processing because i i
couldn't believe it when i saw that he
said it
but he said something to the effect of
like the labor market is strong which
makes me question or makes us question
the gdp data
and
it seems like we're heading into taboo
you know kind of land where
it's not very often you see a central
banker mention that they may not believe
the data
because it seems like they usually
they're pointing like just believe the
data believe the data and it's the
market who's like we don't believe the
data
do you read into that or is that just
maybe he just said kind of offhand
comment and and we shouldn't really take
it uh anything more than that
uh you know i and so it i don't know if
it was an offhand comment i think he's
correct in the sense that you know the
fed is not
they don't have a gdp mandate right like
so the fed is at the end of the day
really doesn't care what gdp does unless
it's really giving them a clear
indication that there's something about
the break
in their employment or inflation
mandates so but and he's actually right
in fact he called this out which is
something you know i was dealing with
for a while earlier in my career which
is uh this was digital seasonality
effect which is you know after the
financial crisis you know every q1 of
every year 2010 2011 2012 and all the
way up through like 2015 i want to say
we saw like a contraction in gdp that
wasn't really real was just a function
of the seasonal adjustment being so
messed up from the uh kind of the height
of the financial crisis so there's some
noise in gdp statistics there's noise in
today's gdp statistics i mean we have a
minus 90 um basis point contraction on
an annualized rate of change basis but
you know 200 to 200 basis points of that
is inventory swings i mean like does
that really impact the economy i mean no
not really i mean don't get me wrong
it's not a great gpu report um you know
you got um you know goods consumption
contracting you know fixed investment
contracting so it's not great but it's
definitely not necessarily as bad as you
might see in terms of seeing oh my god
two back to back um negative gdp reports
so um what really matters is ultimately
to the fed as their proxy for growth is
just monitoring developments in the
labor market because that's at the end
of the day that's what they care about
that's their mandate we've seen bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies they're still down
significantly off the all-time high but
they're up uh in some cases you know 20
30 40 off the bottom
up 80 off the low right depending on
what you're looking at uh and so again
could that be the bottom maybe could it
go lower sure but just the recent price
movement over the last 48 72 hours has
been very positive how do you read
something that i think many people look
at bitcoin specifically as like the most
free market asset that we have it
responds positively to
fed hikes it doesn't necessarily get
punished when the gdp numbers come out
what's your takeaway from that
yeah no great question so yesterday was
a step in the direction of of positive
news from the fed from the new from the
fed we just don't necessarily believe
that it's sustainable in terms of the
market reaction but we can unpack that
later in terms of what's happened the
last you know kind of let's call it 48
hours you know the fed removed forward
guidance from its you know kind of um
you know policy communications which
means that they're going to be a lot
more sort of data not that they weren't
already but they will be expressly data
dependent as it relates to getting into
each incremental meeting you know
they're not going to be guiding towards
75 or 50 basis point rate hikes that
doesn't mean we're not going to get
incremental 75 or 50 baseball right now
it's just that they're not comfortable
guiding to it because they understand
that we're finally in the part of the
process where we are starting to see you
know some significant economic
deterioration that may ultimately um you
know assist uh in their fight against
inflation so they don't they don't want
to overdo it powell definitely said that
very expressly but he also acknowledged
that he's comfortable over doing it if
inflation does not behave on the
timetable which with which they they
wanted to behave
and as you see some of this playing out
obviously housing is just being
destroyed
yeah what what's your read on the
housing market and it just feels
like that's not coming back anytime soon
until they you know put us back sub two
percent or even sub one percent interest
rate like what's your read i mean
housing's toast for this economic cycle
right like you know you're not going to
get a significant decline in rates until
you get through recession and you don't
want to be like housing is not a place
that people go speculate on or even you
know um you know uh consume from a
capital good perspective and heading
into recession so we probably have to
wait till we get to the other side of
the real recession um to really think
about housing um but you know you you
know a few statistics i'll throw at you
like you know the leading indicators for
housing are literally like
falling off the map i'm serious like the
the nahb of the national association of
home builders puts out this housing
market index survey it's basically like
the pmi for the housing market more or
less and the the rate i think that the
level it landed on but the the rate of
change the month over month decline in
the series was the biggest month over
month decline in the time series ever
going back to 1985 excluding uh april of
2020 which is the lockdowns you got the
other leading indicators like housing
starts and building permits are
contracting at down 40 percent
annualized rates of change on a
three-month annualized basis so like i
mean literally the housing market is
like light switch click it's dark i mean
it's serious it's falling off the bottom
of the page
the last question i have for you is
recession uh
two negative quarters of gdp growth a
lot of people say it's a recession it
means technical definition uh president
united states he claims it doesn't uh
federal reserve treasury they say that
it doesn't uh
i haven't heard anyone yet ask
explicitly if two negative quarters of
gdp is not a recession then can you
please define recession
because it sounds like their answer
right now would be uh yeah sure the nber
will uh tell you when it's a recession
and when it's not
of which i don't know a single person at
the mber i don't think anyone else in
the world could name someone there uh it
seems to be this like fictional
organization that just like makes [ __ ]
up uh kind of the ministry of truth for
economics
[Laughter]
honestly like we you talk about him it's
like i think of like
seven or eight like very old no offense
to anybody who's not young uh very old
people wearing like baggy
suits from like the 1990s you know with
like pocket protectors and like you know
very ill colored shirts and ties and
they're like they've got like ruled line
paper like is this the recession
smoking pipes and cigars do you want to
know the funniest part about this
i'm going to say something that most
people don't know and they're going to
be like wait what
when the president of the united states
federal reserve chairman and the
treasury secretary all say
two negative quarters of gdp growth is
not a recession a recession is defined
by the national bureau of economic
research it makes you me and everyone
else believe that's a government
organization
the national bureau of economic research
is a private nonprofit
at what point does the government say
that someone in the private market gets
to decide when there's a [ __ ]
recession or not
i i i normally would be right there with
you you and i agree on 99.9 percent of
things the only reason i disagree with
you here is because
if
you allow the government to determine
what a recession was then there never be
any recessions because no government is
ever going to indict itself and say hey
we [ __ ] up so bad in the economy and
it turned into a recession like you know
biden is a bit he's been doing sort of
like um you know he's been backtracking
on this and trying to prepare people for
this print for for weeks now right like
you know no no no sitting congress or
white house is ever going to say we're
in recession so i think this came up
back in the you know maybe in the 50s or
the 70s you know when we kept having
like you know intermittent recessions
and whatnot and they were like look we
got to put this to the private sector
because if we allow the the government
to tell you they're going to continue
live
there's been over 30
different
edits
to the recession page on wikipedia
allegedly in the last week
wait what
again that's wild let's say that that
number is wrong is only 10.
why are we editing it in the middle of a
recession
yeah why are we editing it at all i mean
we haven't had a real business cycle
recession since 2008 2009. if you go to
the national bureau of economic research
wikipedia page
in it there's a section that says
recession markers it's like kind of a
whole uh section that talks about it and
it's my favorite part the second
sentence of this section says the nber
has come to serve the role as an
official and i'm putting that in air
quotes but it's literally in quote marks
on the page
arbiter of whether the u.s is in a
recession or not
how do you say official
but then put it in quote marks
like why not
it's i mean again it's
the the silver lining in all this is
that we have people like you we have
people like me who can analyze the data
and we don't need to sit around and wait
for the nbr to tell us we're in
recession or not right i mean uh you
know we'll be faithfully with you you
know and then many forms and formats you
know certainly here at 42 macro to tell
you hey look this looks like a recession
you know we know what to look for it's a
decline in income decline in employment
decline and output spans across sectors
of the economy last for multiple months
and again yeah i wish you could see my
screen of literally probably 200 data
points that i'm looking at right now you
know i can tell you if it was a
recession now we don't need to wait on
the nbr
i think that that's the big thing the
last thing i'm going to say is uh
somebody tweeted me today when i was
tweeting about monetary policy
mismanagement allegedly and they said uh
what makes you what makes you think
you're an expert at monetary policy and
my response to them was the premise of
your question insinuates that you think
they're an expert at monetary policy
totally and no one is an expert and i
think that's what we're finding out now
is that you have
similar to what you've seen in other
industries where the barrier to analysis
has dropped to near zero and now people
have access to the data doesn't mean
that anyone is right doesn't guarantee
anyone's success but you have more
voices evaluating the data and
that should be a positive
i think that it's a positive i think
that it's driven more of a conversation
but when you think about recession
are we in a recession like would you
classify this as a recession
no but i think we'll be in one by the
end of the year
what needs to change between now and the
end of the year for you to say yes we're
in a recession
uh to get you to a recession you need to
have a legitimate corporate profit
recession that causes companies to
really start to pull back on hiring and
start firing people um i don't think
we're going to get to negative um
non-farm payroll prints on terms of job
creation by the end of the year but you
might actually get to the peak you know
sometime in q4 or q1 of next year um and
then ultimately the nbr will look back
and say well this process might have
started in september or december again i
don't think the purpose of of risk
management is not just to be specific
with the actual date we'll learn what
date they decide to choose um you know
after the fact what we're trying to do
here is get markets right right and make
money in financial markets and so
ultimately you need to be positioned you
know if the market is not fully priced
in recession which we do not believe it
has then you need to be positioned
accordingly um and if you you believe
that the market's priced it in then you
then uh as you position accordingly for
that but then there you got to make a
call you got to have position on if you
want to make money in financial markets
i think that's a very great place to uh
to end my friend thank you so much where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about 42 macro
yeah appreciate you bro thank you so
much man uh we're at 42macro.com come
check us out we got research for
everybody uh it's consumable and we made
a lot of cool changes here we did put
out a nice little survey a couple weeks
ago got a lot of good feedback and uh
some made some nice uh improvements to
our research so come check that out and
then uh follow me on twitter at 42 macro
deep dale having some fun out there
cheers man
the best macro research in the world i
appreciate you very much
we will uh we will continue to have
these conversations for everyone who's
worried about it we're gonna figure out
which uh which format and how we're
gonna do it but uh i appreciate everyone
tuning in
i know you're doing a good job because
somebody said that you're making them
nervous with your uh information so
i don't want to make him nervous man i
want to make him money that's it
all right let's talk soon
be good man be good hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time